the playstation 4 had an incredible year
with game releases but there is much
more you can gift owners and would-be
owners of Sony's console this is
GameSpot's Holiday Gift Guide for the
PlayStation 4 first things first if
someone on your list is a gamer but
doesn't have a PlayStation 4 get on the
PlayStation 4 slim the ps4 slim comes
with either 500 gigabytes or one
terabyte of internal storage and also
find them bundled with either Call of
Duty World War 2 or in charging for the
console itself is nice and compact and
it's the perfect entry point to play
PlayStation 4 games now if you really
want to ball out for someone get them a
PlayStation 4 Pro this triple layered
monster can be found with either 500
gigabytes or 1 terabytes worth of
internal storage well what makes the ps4
Pro special is that it's much stronger
than the base console the most important
thing to note though is if they really
want to take advantage of the ps4 pros
power bill need a 4k HDR TV Pro enhanced
games will render higher resolutions and
the lighting will look a lot better now
if that person on your shopping list
already has a PlayStation 4 consider
getting them the PlayStation VR
psvr really took a step forward this
year with the release of games like
resident evil 7 and Skyrim VR these are
full-fledged games you can play in
virtual reality if you are gonna get a
PS VR for someone make sure you get the
one that's bundled with a PlayStation
camera because that's how it tracks
motion even if you have a 1 terabyte
hard drive on the PlayStation 4 it's
going to run out real quick if you're
downloading games solve that problem get
someone a Western Digital my passport
portable hard drive it's a simple
straightforward hard drive that connects
through USB 3.0 4 relatively fast data
transfer and the extra 2 terabytes is an
uncommon clutch if you want to give
someone the gift of sound hook them up
with the Sony Gold wireless stereo
headset check out right here this
headset sports a sleek minimalist design
and it's very light and light on the
head this comes with the USB dongle so
it can be used wirelessly with the ps4
but also comes with a 3.5 millimeter
audio cable if you want to use this on
any other device the gold wireless
headset is durable and looks great
sounds great and it does 7.1 virtual
surround sound the standard Dual Shock 4
is a fine controller but if you want to
get them something a little bit fancier
I would recommend the scuf infinity or
PS pro there are a couple things that
make this controller special like the
grippy analog sticks my thumbs ever slip
off of them like they tend to do on the
standard Dual Shock 4 and the most
important part is the programmable
paddles on the back you have two of them
on this controller and you can map them
to act as any other button just comes in
clutch for FPS games so you never have
to take your thumbs off the analog
sticks but if that's someone on your
list is perfectly fine with the Dual
Shock 4 but does need an extra
controller you get a little fancy and
get them a translucent version there's
nothing too special about this since
it's exactly like the original
controller but you can see inside now if
you still can't decide on a gift for a
PlayStation 4 owner it's a safe bet to
get them a PS plus membership this will
give them access to playing online
multiplayer games and special sales on
the PlayStation Store if you really want
to go all out this holiday season hook
them up with the TCL 55 P 605 4k HDR TV
it's one of the best options out
when you factor in affordability and it
comes with roku support built-in these
are some of the essentials that we
recommend this holiday season when it
comes to the PlayStation 4 now all you
have to do is make a decision give your
gift and watch a smile on their face as
they open up their present if you still
need more ideas head on over to
gamespot.com for all our gift guides
thanks for watching and we'll see you
soon
[Music]